[Music]
we had an idea which was to take an
entire episode of this show and then
re-air it entirely in the minecraft
style animated like why I made a Bicol
show in the beginning could end all
minecraft style and well that sounds
like it would be a lot of fun I know
would be a lot of fun we got excited
that's what we were you know all
thinking this could be great and but the
problem is when we asked the Minecraft
people if we could do it initially they
said yes we got very excited yeah then
they suddenly change their mind and they
told us we don't want you to do it well
that seems really crazy especially in
light of the fact that the Internet is
just packed with fan made minecraft
videos that they're perfectly fine yeah
those are everywhere we asked if we
could do it they said first yes then I
would rather you not do it and I thought
well what's the harm everyone else is
doing it you know and I thought we'd do
it and the sad thing is now we'll never
know what we would have looked like in a
Minecraft universe yeah it's too bad
yeah I mean I know it would have made me
look really cool who knows I mean I
would have loved to have seen our show
in the Minecraft style
yeah we could have had like a Minecraft
me imagine what a Minecraft you would
look like no I'm already blocky enough
and you do carry an axe and I knock away
at things and that's true we could have
guessed come on and it look in minecraft
style right and the fact is the people
who are saying no to us about doing it
they could only benefit from it yes it
could only benefit from seeing you and
me and the guys in the band well not all
the guys in the band that takes too much
work we could probably have one of them
you know lebombo he's pretty easy to
draw a simple line yeah mustache hat
that's about it yeah and we'd have fun
shots like you'd see the audience in
Minecraft right I
and then anything could happen we could
be we could be on a pirate ship oh that
would be cool we could be in a castle
for once oh I would love to be in a
castle
but if we were in some sort of deep pit
for part of the show that would be great
the point is us in Minecraft I think is
a winner it's a real shame Conan a real
shame folks we'll take a break we'll be
right back
[Applause]
you